Welcome back everybody to our
lecture on parsing and let's
make a toast on our first monad.
That's great. Now we can move on.
Let's look at
another operator
on parsers that really
makes it into a monad
and that is namely sequencing of parsers.
So what we want to do is we want to take
a parser
and not try the other one if the first
one fails
but we want to sequentially
compose them. So we want to run
one parser
and then when it is terminated, we want to
run the next parser. And for that we are
going to use the so-called do syntax
and the do syntax
that's one of the advantages of having a
monad, because now you can write
code that makes this
sequential composition clear. So here is
what we want to
write. We want to write the following.
We want to say
try to parse an item
call that x. Parse another item.
I don't care about that one, so I don't
give it a name.
Then parse a third item. Call that y.
And then return the pair of x,y.
So what you see here is that we are
sequencing
these three parses of items
and we are just returning the first
and the last.
If you look at this code here
remember that we talked about the layout
rule, so
all these things here must be lined up
really nice. You can also put curly
braces
and semicolons in here. That is actually
what I usually do
when I use the do notation, because
then it looks even more like imperative
code.
And as we already showed
if you don't put this left arrow
in there
then the parser is called, but the
result is
discarded.
The other thing is that
when we are composing parsers, multiple
parsers in a row
what we want to have is that when
any of them fails, the whole thing will
fail. And then we can always
try with the triple plus to
use another parser.
So if we parse here p
that was our example here
it would take this guy and
parses three characters and returns the
first
and the third. So it returns this. But
if we try to
apply that to a string that only has
two characters
then it won't work. So it will fail.
It will fail, you see it here.
Failing, there... I'm failing
like the parser.
When any parser that you sequentially
compose fails, you want the whole
thing to fail. And the other thing
is that the real
advantage of having a monad is not
that it makes you look smart.
It is not that you are a cool kid.
It is not that you can write
the millionth blog post on explaining
monads.
The real advantage of monads is
that you can
use the do notation.
That is all there is to it.
Not a big deal. Let's
continue
writing some more parsers. Here in this
case
assuming that we have this parser
that can do sequential composition
we are going to write
the following function, that takes a
predicate
from character
to Bool and returns a parser
for characters. So here it is:
sat p
So we are looking for a character that
satisfies p.
We parse an item that will return x.
If p holds, then we immediately return x
and we don't change the input.
If p of x
does not hold, then we have to
fail. So this is
quite obvious. We try to parse any item.
Then we check whether the predicate holds.
If it holds
we use the parser that always succeeds and
if the predicate does not hold, we
use the parser that always fails.
So those came in quite handy.
Let's use this
parser now to write some interesting
things. So say that we want to parse a
digit.
Well, what we can is we can say use
this sat
with isDigit. So now this thing will
try to parse a character
check whether it's a digit. In that case
it will immediately succeed
with that digit. If it is not a digit,
it will fail
immediately. If we want to parse
a specific character, here
so that is character x, then we can
use sectioning
to create a predicate
(x==). So this is a function that
expects a character and checks whether
it is equal to x
and then we apply that to sat.
So here you see a quite nice use of
sectioning.
In case you wondered why on earth is this
weird sectioning in Haskell
here you have an example of this.
Some people say
there is an x here and there is an x there
I can write this in pointfree style. So
maybe you should try that.
You can write this thing here
in pointfree style. But again as I
warned you
when you use pointfree style with function
composition and so on
your code might become quite unreadable
very quickly. But in this case I think
it's a nice challenge
to write this one pointfree. It will look
quite nice. Let's look at the next one
here.
This is a parser that tries to parse p
zero or more times. And you see this
often. It is like a regular expression or
a repetition. And I want to find
zero or more digits. Or if I want to
parse an
identifier, I want to parse a letter
followed by zero or more identifiers
or digits.
So this often happens
when you are trying to parse things.
Here we see: many
takes a Parser of a and returns a Parser
of list of a. And guess what?
This is defined recursively. So many of p
first tries to parse at least one p
and if that fails, it returns
the empty list. It would be
slightly nicer to use the
parser that always fails there.
How do we write many1?
We define that in terms of many
so we have here
a mutual recursive definition. So if I
want to parse p
one or more times, I try to parse p once.
I get the value v. Then I try to
parse zero or more times p.
I get the value. This can be the empty
list
if I return the empty list...
I have to apologize. This is really
returning the empty list. That's not failing
because
if I parse p zero or more times, I can
parse it one time or zero times.
And in the case of zero times, I have to
return the empty
list.
That was something there. So if we
parse it there
so we get zero or more times, and then
we return
v concatenated with vs.
So this is the one times and this is
the many times.
So this is like a subtle mutual recursion
and very subtle. Even Erik made a
mistake there
so you better pay attention.
The last thing here is we are going to
define a function, that tries to parse a
string.
So far we have seen many examples where
we were trying to parse
a character, but I want to parse a string.
And remember strings are just lists of
characters.
So if I start with the empty list
I just return the empty list, the
empty string.
If I try to parse the character (x:xs)
I try to parse the character x,
I recursively try to parse a
string that represents the rest of this
thing and then
I return
the result. I found an x.
I return that and I return that, so I just
return the string. So this just checks
whether this string
is the prefix of my input.
So now we can define a parser that
consumes a list
of one or more digits from a string. So
this is starting to become more like
parsing
an actual language. What do we do?
We want to parse a list
so we have to parse an open brace
and a close brace.
We are not interested in those values,
so you don't see
a left arrow there. Then we are trying to
parse a digit
and then we are trying to parse many
characters
comma digits. Because we want to have
a list
of one or more digits. So there is one
digit
and then the more digits here
and then we just concatenate those digits
with the other digits. Here you
see
how we take all these
elementary parsers and combine them
together
to write already
pretty complicated parsers like this.
If we
apply this parser here on the list
well, it's a string
but we want to parse that string as a list
we will see that we get the
digits 1234. And if we are trying to
parse it on something that is
not a proper list
we will get an error.
Of course, as we said, this is a
super simple parser. If you want to write
a real parser, if you want to use
a parser in real code, you typically want
to do something smarter, when
there are errors than just returning
the empty list.
At least you want to give the position
in the input list where things go wrong.
Or you want to try to
correct errors or whatever. But again
we are trying to
cover here the very very basics of parsing.
And there's plenty of parsing libraries
for Haskell
and for other languages that are based
on the same idea
that add all these more sophisticated
features.
Thank you very much and see you
in the next part.